et je vous le disais en titre nous
allons parler golf aujourd'hui avec la
100e édition de l'open de france de golf
qui démarre donc que ce jeudi à saint
quentin en yvelines
plus de soixante mille personnes sont
attendues sur les greens pour voir les
26 français en compétition mais aussi
les têtes d'affiché comme reuil mcelroy
victor dubuisson ou encore alexander
levy je vous propose d'aller jeter un
coup d'oeil à cette première journée de
compétition
michael almy d'euros notre journaliste
sportif et sur place pour prendre la
température
oui flora nous sommes au golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous sommes
avec paul hermitage le responsable du
golf national à l'heure paul cette
première journée et était vraiment
intense sur les greens absolument c'est
parfait un temps sur les greens et en
dehors des greens parce qu'on a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de monde mais vous les
scores c'est parfait on a un français
qui est qui dans le top 3 là pour le
moment et et tout porte à espoir que en
aura pas mal de français parce qu'il
joue plutôt bien sur leur parcours oui
les français se débrouillent pas mal
mais tout à fait tout à fait largement
au dessus au mieux que la moyenne en art
henry nott stars qui nous a fait venir
un énorme public aujourd'hui donc ça on
n'a jamais vu autant de monde à jeudi le
premier jour du tournoi qu'aujourd'hui
ça c'est sûr justement on va regarder
les réactions sur la venue de rory
mcilroy bah ça représente une grosse
star un grand joueur qui a beaucoup
d'avenir
hélas en mousseline déjà il s'énerve pas
beaucoup yart ses nerfs et sa mort spear
à jouer bosch content parce que c'est la
première fois que je le vois et sam en
side vraiment à jouer dès qu'on a appris
la nouvelle il était décidé conviendrait
pour cet open de france
monfils en rêve depuis deux ans il a
même fait un devoir d'école cette année
sur rory mcilroy
donc il était évident qu'on pouvait pas
rater cet événement je dirais que ça
représente un modèle
l'exemple du sportif mais qui a aussi
que les bons côtés du sportif épaules
tous les mauvais côtés qu'on peut voir
dans d'autres sports bon en tout cas
paul ils sont ravis de voir rory mcilroy
ici à saint quentin en yvelines
oui oui nous gâte rory en étant là parce
que il est quand même comme vous dites
numéro trois mondial il ya un grand
tournoi un championnat du monde qui se
déroule en exactement en même temps sur
et aux états unis mais il a choisi de
venir ici parce que c'est le centième
open de france parce que c'est le
parcours de la ryder cup dans deux ans
c'est un repère h pour lui aussi parce
qu'on vient de faire les travaux comme
vous savez on en a beaucoup parlé et il
n'a pas joué le parcours depuis 2010 et
effectivement nous on le sent dans tout
ce qui est vivant de billetterie c'est
un impact non négligeable sur
l'événement vous pouvez chiffré cet
impact
oui on peut vous donner des tendances
en pré vente c'est-à-dire les commandes
de billetterie sur internet en a vendu
40 % de plus que l'année dernière et on
est à peu près au niveau des ventes
aujourd'hui ce soir dans la totalité de
l'année dernière donc en trois jours qui
restent et çà vous pousse encore plus
peut-être attirer des têtes d affiche
oui bah c'est la preuve que ce type de
politique stratégie marche mais la
stratégie de l'open de france et de
privilégier tout le plateau c'est à dire
de ne pas à payer ce qu'on appelle de
monique ne pas payer les joueurs pour
venir la dotation est déjà très élevé
salle avoisine quatre millions d'euros à
chaque année
c'est d'ailleurs le tournoi le plus doté
sur le continent européen derrière un ou
deux tournois en angleterre donc c'est
pas notre politique pour le moment donc
il faut qu'on trouve les moyens de
garder cette relation qu'on a
actuellement avec danny willett avec
rory dany boon qui a gagné le premier
majeur de l'année le master's qui sont
venus faire l'honneur à la france cette
semaine
et est ce que c'est le plus beau open de
france de l'histoire
écoutez ce serait mal placé de ma part
de dire oui pour nous aujourd'hui c'est
le plus beau pourquoi parce que on vient
de passer une période intense de travaux
sur le parcours
tout de suite derrière l'open de france
l'année dernière on a fermé le parcours
le cloître à bord je le rappelle
oui c'est ça avec 130 personnes par jour
une dizaine d'entreprises qui
intervenait on a carrément bouleversé le
parcours est donc d'ouvrir le 1er mai
attendant les budgets en plus et avoir
un open six semaines après avec les
pires pluies qu'on n'ait jamais connue
ici aussi pour nous c'est une belle
récompense
cette première journée et les retours
sont positifs de la part des joueurs oui
très positif on a des retours
on a pas de retours négatifs on a des
très bons retours sur les changements du
parcours les changements sur le dessin
notamment sur le quatre 5e 1 le grain
juin le green du cese évidemment on
savait que c'était humide parce que
comment on sait qu'il a beaucoup plu
mais les retours sont hyper positif il
ya eu beaucoup de choses sur les réseaux
sociaux hier soir les joueurs sont
repartis après leur entraînement
ils ont beaucoup de tweets et des choses
vraiment sympa comme quoi c'est c'est le
un des parcours si c'est une balle le
parcours qui préfère dans l'année est un
des plus difficiles sur le plan sportif
rory mcilroy pour l'instant au 23e
victor dubuisson le français superstar
ici à saint quentin divine est également
23e
ils ont fait un score plutôt logique
oui je pense qu'ils ont rempli leur
contrat de la première journée la
première journée c'est toujours un peu
difficile parce que effectivement il ya
la foule
deuxièmement prori par exemple il a joué
le parcours pour la première fois un
hier après six ans d'absence donc et
c'est qu'une reconnaissance du parcours
avant le jour j et par aujourd'hui sera
je pense largement dans le code pour
demain soir
donc oui je pense qu'ils ont rempli leur
contrat se sont pas éloignés de la tête
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire et ils
sont pas en tête non plus ce qui leur
laisse par la pression demain et si vous
deviez faire un pronostic sur cet open
de france
vous êtes un gentil parce que alors je
vais jouer qu'au repos et je vais dire
un français ok c'est noté voilà florane
peut être un français gagnera l'open de
france
selon paul hermitage merci michael alors
réponse ce dimanche le vainqueur
pourrait être connu aux alentours de 18
heures